alright I'm here with the guys from
mega64 hello gentlemen hello hello hey
guys go around the horn and introduce
yourselves I am Sean Chatfield hello hi
I'm Rocco Bodie and I'm Derek Acosta so
you guys have been making game themed
youtube you know parodies video skits
all that kind of stuff for like 6 years
on YouTube now
yes ears on YouTube but we were around
before YouTube we've started this is our
10th year of doing this actually what
were you doing before YouTube just
putting videos on our site you could
download angelfire dot-com yeah yes it
was like 30 megabyte you know WMV files
so kind of like a beber in YouTube I
missed that really flash is too easy
I pay for bandwidth so it sucks that we
can't do that so much yeah I miss
talking with our hosting guy used to put
links on our website you can download
the videos and watch them on your own
computer on your own time
ya know when YouTube came out did it
like did it blow you guys mind that
there was this thing that like was so
much easier to upload your videos and
post it was well it was I didn't know
anything about it really yeah it was
kind of cool that like oh you can kind
of just streaming off this thing but I
didn't know if it would be any kind of
permanent whatever and it was just to me
it was a makeshift solution like it was
it was like sometime in 2006 and we
needed to give our we did it just on a
Resident Evil 4 skit and we were like
well we need an easy way to show this to
a bunch of people because if we were
gonna premiere it on some on a cable
show and so we were like well we'll just
put it on this YouTube site and we'll
give them the link okay
and so I made like my own just a screen
name with my own name in it you know it
was like Rocco Rocco be 64 and then we
put it on that account and it got and
yeah I think it's got like six or seven
million hits and it was like well I
guess this is hence our YouTube name is
still it's not like mega64 channel or
whatever it's like Rocco be 64 yeah
that's just me yeah this is his show
look at me the main guy infect
um so of course this is gonna be the
internet on the Internet okay so there's
gonna be some who's like oh
those guys aren't real nerds you know of
course you're gonna get that so just to
get it out of the way if you guys just
tell me your favorite video games of
2012 that'll be our you know that will
be our test all right who to tie for me
two of them madden 13 and call of duty
black guy see so he knows what he's
talking about
don't get it twisted guys in their
trench I was screwed don't get chopped
and screwed remix don't slow this down
um my favorite game of you know what I
got a tie as well legit this year my
favorite games were I don't know if it
counts as a 2012 game it came out
everywhere else in 2011 but here
Xenoblade Chronicles baby believe that
and actually a portable game Resident
Evil Revelations on the 3ds was like
very well done I thought it was like
cinematic and great it was good and well
I mean super easy and you know have you
guys played Angry Birds Star Wars
because that is legit and it's only
$0.99 so if you don't have it honor your
phone all right what do you already gave
the joke answer you all right how you
two cancel each other out I played a lot
of XCOM this year and I started playing
PC games for the first time ever so I
played a lot of hotline Miami you know
that's cool that was a cool I like
stupid simple computer games like
anything I can be in 20 minutes and then
keep playing day after day after day
that's what I'm into you know you have
to give a real answer shoot you know it
honestly it just came out but it needs
to admire bothers you I like it like
super super into like I've I really am
enjoying that and I know it's a brand
new game it's very recent but screw all
the other games this year to sucks I
felt like this wasn't a good year for
games
what yeah it was just kind of blase I
feel like we're at the end of era as far
as the generation of consoles I feel
like everybody's waiting for the next
big thing but but no company is really
delivering like maybe in three years or
so when the new consoles are out and
they've been established and people who
have gotten used
the equipment will see some new cool
stuff but everything that's coming out
now feels like we've kind of done it all
before you know and the Wii the Wii U
came out nice and I've had some fun with
the system but even that like the launch
games were kinda like oh okay so Mario
you know whatever but I'll be excited to
see what comes of it
so you guys are kind of you know you
could say that you guys are authorities
in game you guys been doing it for a
long time you even make you play a lot
of video games so you love be good you
kind of its kind of your career you know
you guys are working on that kind of
yeah idea sure when it comes to the
console wars PlayStation Xbox Wii when
the new systems come out what do you
guys think is gonna take it you know
what we were just talking about this and
I feel like for me and thank you for
them but like Nintendo will always be
like the place to play like the games
there I made my childhood that's like I
love Nintendo for that reason and I'm
ready to install joke about Nintendo and
that's like my company if I had to
choose one just because it's my I had a
kid it was awesome but uh I honestly I'm
like getting disgusted with Microsoft
like I am so over like having to pay for
like live and all that stuff like I
don't care like for me the PlayStation
is just like a perfect package of
everything that you would want in a
console yeah everything when I turn on
my X I like can't handle more ads like
that the Xbox experience is kind of like
muddled to me but but yeah I end up
using probably the ps3 more than
anything so so if there's another
console I'm more excited about a new
PlayStation I guess even though I still
like I like my ps3 I don't I don't play
it and go I wish I had my fourth one you
know so I don't know I feel like
PlayStation does everything the Xbox
does and does it for free but the Xbox
still wins for whatever reason you know
I think I'm the same way I played
multiplayer online a PlayStation pull
the player online Xbox yeah yeah you
still can't deny that like the online
structure is still so much better I got
one of my favorite games of last year
and this year I played it forever was
Skyrim and I got that on PlayStation 3
cuz I thought the graphics will be
better you know it's like there's a
single-player game there's no
multiplayer the only determining factor
for me between which console I'm gonna
get it on is the graphics so I got on
the ps3 and now it's like they released
Dawnguard on the Xbox they released the
new Dragonborn DLC all this stuff is
coming out
Fox I feel totally screwed yeah I'm
never buying a PlayStation 3 game again
unless it's exclusive well yeah I was
gonna say that I should preface like I
play I am big on single-player so I
think that's kind of deciding thing for
me too
the the Xbox might be worth it for cuz
the online is still so much better and
more established but I'm very into
single-player stuff you know with the
exclusives that Sony has with like
Uncharted and like especially coming out
they've got that that game beyond coming
out and like the Last of Us and things
like that
that's my speed like I'm I'm not you
definitely play online a lot more than I
think either of the worst gaming guys
ever played of all time all time I
played a Superman 64
oh yeah that sucked horrendous my
brother bought that game it waste mmm
there's okay I'm gonna go obscure here
regular Nintendo original NES the
adventures of Dino Riki Dino Ricky was
this kid he could take special power
dinosaur pellets whatever and become a
macho guy good luck finding less pal you
do that maybe two times you're dead
it is just a sea of dinosaurs
on him and you can't progress when when
you're a kid and back then it was like
30 50 bucks to get a game that was not
you know that's not easy you know
whatever especially if you couldn't try
it at anything there was no place I
don't even know if he could rent games
at that point those dinosaurs man Dino
Riki you suck and you know it ya know
they're better not if there's a dino
Ricky - I'll see to it does it finish
I don't have any games that stand out as
like things that I hated when I played
them but I remember I went back a few
years ago and popped in a 64 and the
only game I think this was at Rocco's
house the only gaming head singer I was
Glover Oh clever yeah Glover 64 realize
all the time when it came out how bad it
was but you play it now as an adult that
thing is terrible yeah the
Hamburger Helper hand running around one
single color-block room it was like the
Simpsons and Crazy Taxi Simpsons row
great that was a great game you're right
that game was great the load time yeah I
think was literally ten minutes to the
point where like I can't I can't play
this game anymore like I can't do this
because I have the time to put into it
yeah those pretty bad but if you think
about it like I like to think of terms
of like expectation of what you should
get versus what you got and really I
think the worst game in recent memory is
honestly probably Resident Evil six is
like one of what happened yeah it was
like I just my jaw was on the ground I'm
just playing this thing where I'm
fighting these zombies made of pudding
that are like flying out of me and I'm
like spazzing out and I'm just like wow
man
you had the world in your hands what
happened here but review from one of the
best video game magazines so you guys I
was just watching you guys the against
the free poster we uploaded the fallout
3 skit where you guys go and do you know
like real life oh yeah I was watching
that one was really funny but the hold
on I was watching I was filled with like
so much anxiety because you guys we're
doing it in front of all these people
and you know you kept getting knocked
down right and people would be like are
you okay are you okay together get
stressed out doing this in public
yeah I get like before the day before we
do it I get like physically ill like I
just I don't feel good like even like
the day I like I'm always like yeah
let's don't have this morning on the
second super nervous and like it it is
never anything it's like oh we're
breaking the law but it's just like I
just it's so stressful it's always worse
I think in your head before you right
before yeah yeah we imagine the
worst-case scenario like they're gonna
call the police
somebody's gonna intervene
like they're gonna think I'm a criminal
they're gonna try to arrest me or detain
me or attack me and then you do it once
or twice and a lot of times we go out
and there's no reaction at all
so we'll go do four or five takes where
we actually build up to what you see in
the videos it's a lot of money trying
something Wow
nobody cares okay we gotta up the ante
let's get even crazier
yeah people still don't care okay and
it's come to points where we get to our
wits ahead yeah you start gonna go crazy
I'm gonna go crazy I'm gonna
push over there about push a display
over yeah I'm gonna go lay facedown on
the ground in the middle of the store
until secure until we get good fun
that's the only way we're gonna get a
video yes but I
yeah it's always nerve-racking right
before I love that I thrive on that
feeling in it I definitely is like like
a pit in my stomach but I think I think
for me it's more of a like I hope we
don't screw up a shot or something cuz
that's the thing is running and gunning
it the way that we do is a lot of times
like did you see when that guy said that
thing to me and it's like no actually a
lot of times it's more nerve-wracking
being the camera oh for sure yeah by the
guy doing it when you're in costume
obviously something is up and worst case
scenario you're an idiot like you can
just tell people I'm stupid look I'm
sorry I wasn't acting like an idiot but
the explanation is I'm really dumb so
but if you're the guy with the camera
then you're you're not the idiot you're
the guy who has to explain it you're
obviously yeah why are you filming can
you plan on doing something with it it's
like you're the authority when you have
it not only that but you're also like
you're along for the ride because if
Bravo decides that he wants to go in the
back and start peeing on like employees
I have to film that that's coming videos
yeah sorry sorry but it's like I never
he isn't doing I have to be there with
him whereas if you're the person in
control it's like I go as far as I'm
comfortable it may be part of them they
are but it's like oh I'm gonna go in
here messes up a little bit and then
leave I know that I'm just like there's
no time I think oh please god he's using
me as an example I really think he hates
being
camera
anytime I'm the subject it because yeah
I will I will make sure like okay I'm
gonna do this for 20 minutes to make
sure we have one goodness living Lee
this is the one of the tria who loves to
go back into the backroom of stores
that's something he finds funny like
into a supermarket like the loading dock
or like where they count all the money
for the hills that's where he wants to
go your costume yeah it's terrifying
yeah because I was watching you're doing
like you were carrying a bunch of stuff
and you're taking all the from the
dudes table mm-hmm that was like oh that
guy's gonna like fight you so so
stressful so you guys do another series
you guys do gamer girls girls and you
you do like personas where you claim to
be gamers material of these kind of like
really frilly games the Harvest Moon
it's a weird kind of message do you guys
think that like it is only the
subsection of girls who aren't really
gamers do you guys think that all girls
have a hard time being true okay the
thing about Harvest Moon
that's something my character said and I
totally said that because there was a
girl who worked in a Gamestop that I
would go to and every time I went into
that Game Stop she would ask me about
some Harvest Moon related thing like do
I want to preorder Harvest Moon go did I
play the latest Harvest Moon like she
thinks this really that's the only game
specifically this one girl would talk
about so that applies to all girls
that's just by coincidence if ik
impersonation um no I mean I don't think
we think that hard about it we just try
to make goofy characters I would say the
only thing that I guess we were trying
to like or that we were I guess poking
fun at was that we encountered a lot of
people getting an e3 that were not
really qualified like just in terms of
the Pratt just like oh I have a YouTube
channel and I'm here but like Will
Wright who's like an amazing icon in
video gaming
yeah his art team couldn't get in to e3
and like stuff like that so I think we
wanted to make some jokes about like
what but that is the that isn't really
something about girls or anything like
that it was just us being nice
that happens in all walks of life guys
can yeah girls we're too young to even
drink get into the club without
presenting ID that's I mean it happens
in games it happens all over I think we
were just portraying no one in
particular but just yeah just it was a
caricature really extreme girls who
happened to be in the video games but
they're really girly as well all right
thanks guys for talking to me I really
appreciate it hey thank you you're
welcome thank thanks for having me
that's perfect sign off one Troy's right
thank you for watching us check us out
mega64 calm best site on the Internet
you heard it here first
youtube.com slash mega64 you checking us
out this is a new media rockstars
exclusive we're the best baby put that
on the way creators of septic v look us
up be there we're gonna be on the front
page and I want to say shout out to the
Honda Pilot Thank You new media
rockstars